escribe un binomio que exprese la
diferencia entre el área de un
rectángulo que mide p de largo y mide 2
r de ancho y el área de un círculo cuyo
diámetro mide 4 r y además nos están
diciendo que p es más grande que 7 r
entonces pues vamos a empezar por
calcular cuál es el área de un
rectángulo que mide p de largo y mide 12
r de ancho entonces digamos que por aquí
está nuestro rectángulo y que además
mide p de largo o sea que esto mide p y
mide 12 r de ancho entonces esto de aquí
mide 2 r entonces cuál será su área su
área cuando tenemos un rectángulo el
área de ese rectángulo siempre es base
por altura entonces esta área toda esta
área va a ser igual a 2 r por p2p
y la otra cosa que tenemos que sacar es
cuál es el área de un círculo cuyo
diámetro mide 4 r entonces dibujemos
porque un círculo ahí está más o menos
nuestro círculo y nos dicen que su
diámetro mide 4 r
más o menos esto de aquí es su diámetro
y esta línea realmente está a la mitad
de este círculo entonces su centro está
por aquí porque hay entonces todo esto
mide 4 r y cómo se le hace para sacar el
área de un círculo pues nosotros tenemos
la fórmula de geometría que nos dice que
el área de un círculo el área del
círculo es igual a y por radio al
cuadrado ok ahora aquí hay que tener
mucho cuidado está r no es la misma r
que está r o que está r de hecho aquí
sería bueno escribir algo así como radio
para que no se confundan las variables
claro que muchas veces cuando estás
trabajando en álgebra te vas a encontrar
con ejercicios que usan la misma
variable que tú estás usando para alguna
otra fórmula entonces es un muy buen
ejercicio ese de reconocer qué variables
son la fórmula y qué variable son de tu
ejercicio y que realmente aunque sean la
misma letra no tienen nada que ver
entonces pues vamos a quitarle sus
letras entonces ahorita lo que tenemos
que averiguar es cuánto vale esta r
aunque hay cuánto vale el radio que no
es esta r el radio es esta distancia que
es exactamente la mitad del diámetro by
la mitad de 4 r así es que este radio
mide 2 r que hay entonces el área de
este círculo es igual y por nuestro
radio que es 2 r este radio al cuadrado
ok el radio mide exactamente 2 r ya
pensé que pues ni modo le vamos a dejar
todas las letras en la palabra radio
pero bueno esto se puede simplificar y
nos queda que él
es igual a 12 r por 2 r es igual a 4 r
al cuadrado entonces esta área la vamos
a escribir como 4 pi por r al cuadrado
donde está r no es de radio es de la r
que nos dieron porque nada más se le ve
este término al cuadrado y lo reacomodo
para que las constantes queden del lado
izquierdo ahora queremos encontrar la
diferencia y la forma de hacer eso es
tomar la resta de cualesquiera de estas
dos áreas y luego sacar el valor
absoluto pero si no queremos poner por
ahí el valor absoluto pues mejor
averigüemos cuál de estas dos áreas es
más grande que la otra y entonces ya
nada más restamos a la más grande y la
más chica y ya encontramos la diferencia
aunque allí para eso lo que vamos a usar
es esta cosa que nos dieron por aquí que
dice que p es más grande que 7 r que es
más grande que 7 r y cómo vamos a usar
eso pues vamos a multiplicar los dos
lados de la desigualdad
2 r y eso no debería de cambiar esta
desigualdad que hay porque 12 r tiene
que ser mayor que 0 porque es cuánto
mide el ancho del rectángulo y estamos
hablando de rectángulos no degenerados o
sea de rectángulos normales en los
cuales pues el ancho tiene que ser mayor
que 0 entonces no se nos voltea este
signo de igual que estamos multiplicando
por 2 r y nos queda igual a 7 por 2 14 r
cuadrada ok 2 rp es mayor que
14 ere cuadrada ahora para que hice eso
de multiplicar por 12 r pues porque
entonces esto de aquí es exactamente
igual al área del rectángulo gei área
área del rectángulo de
ángulo y esto de aquí aunque todavía no
es claro tiene mucho que ver con el área
de este círculo de hecho es mayor que el
área del círculo aquí pero está esa
relación la tenemos que destacar con
todo cuidado tenemos por aquí cuatro
people r al cuadrado y cuánto vale pi
pues pib al 3.14 15 92 65 35 blablabla
una infinidad de decimales a la derecha
pero tú no te tienes que aprender todo
eso que hay generalmente se redondea
como pi igual a
3.14
16 en lugar de 3.14 15 92 65 35 y bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla pero
resulta que 14 lo podemos escribir como
4 x
3.5 que tal vez debería describir un
paréntesis por aquí este es un punto
decimal y este es un punto de que se
están multiplicando y pues pi como es
3.14
16 definitivamente es más chico que 3.5
esto es mayor que 4 por ti
entonces lo que tenemos es que el área
del círculo
área
círculo que es igual a 4 por pi por r al
cuadrado otra vez r tiene que ser mayor
que 0 entonces en esta desigualdad
podemos multiplicar de los dos lados por
r al cuadrado y es mayor que 0 entonces
no se voltea esta desigualdad entonces
esto es menor estricto a 4 x 3.5 eso es
por esta desigualdad de aquí pero pues 4
por 3.5 es 14 entonces podemos poner 14
por r al cuadrado r al cuadrado esta
desigualdad es tal cual simplemente
multiplicar por r al cuadrado de los dos
lados de esta desigualdad ok pero esto
de aquí ya es exactamente igual a esto
entonces 14 r al cuadrado termino siendo
mayor que 4 x pi por r al cuadrado
el área del círculo entonces el área del
rectángulo es más grande que el área del
círculo si ésta es más grande que 7
veces esta ere y entonces para expresar
como un binomio como un binomio la
diferencia entre estas dos áreas
vamos a tomar esta área que es la más
grande que es 2 reporte y le vamos a
restar el área de este círculo que es 4
x pi x r al cuadrado y ya terminamos